la france condamné par la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme pour
avoir sanctionné des militants
pro-palestiniens en faveur du boycott de
produits importés d'israël la saisie en
2016 par le collectif palestine 68 parle
d'une violation de la liberté
d'expression pour les juges de
strasbourg cela relève le site
d'expression politique et militante
concernant un sujet d'intérêt général
l'état français va devoir verser des
dommages et intérêts aux requérants on
va justement en parler avec antoine
comte quête avocats du bds bonjour à
vous merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors cette décision de la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
très attendu est ce que c'est une
surprise son verdict écoutez on va pas
parler de surprise ou au contraire de
méprise on va parler de ce mouvement en
faveur de la liberté d'expression à un
moment particulièrement critique en
france et en europe où cette liberté
d'expression subi des assauts répétés
inquiétant donc je suis très heureux de
cette décision
elle pose des principes qui me
paraissent essentiels à savoir que les
citoyens ont le droit de critiquer la
politique d'un état étranger ou français
bien évidemment que cette critique du
moment qu'elle pose pas des appels à la
violence ou à la discrimination est
acceptable
elle est couverte par ce qu'on appelle
l'article 10 de la convention européenne
je veux dire l'arctique qui protège la
liberté de la communication est liberté
d'expression c'est donc une une décision
pour moi intéressante
à un moment un peu charnière où il
fallait qu'il y ait un coup d'arrêt
donné à des attaques contre la liberté
d'expression
l'appel au boycott est reconnu comme un
droit citoyen s'est réjouie
l'association france palestine dans un
france palestine solidarité dans un
communiqué ce que vous êtes d'accord
vous avec ce point de vue sur le plan
juridique
alors c'est une évidence pour moi
puisque l'appel au boycott est
simplement une façon de poser un
problème politique qui doit être résolu
par les moyens du droit et de ce point
de vue là il ya une décision qui est
rendue donc aujourd'hui avec une opinion
partiellement dissidente dissidente de
la présidente de la formation de la cour
européenne qui est madame en lui et qui
dit quand même il faut rappeler que le
premier acte de bohicon date de 1880 et
que c'était des paysans irlandais qui
protestaient contre la façon dont ils
étaient employés par un propriétaire
terrien et elle relève entre entre cette
période là et la période aujourd'hui les
dizaines et des dizaines d'appels au
boycott qui n'ont jamais ton des
problèmes donc il faut reconnaître aux
citoyens le droit d'appeler au boycott
de produits et c'est très important
c'est une opinion politique
elle est protégée par la convention
actuelle c'est quand même la deuxième
fois depuis le début du mois que la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme
condamne la france deuxième fois depuis
début du mois puisqu'il y aussi la faire
marina cette petite fille de 8 ans
portant en 2009 sous les coups de ses
parents la cour européenne reproche à la
france de ne pas avoir pris des mesures
suffisantes
ces condamnations concrètement simple
puis quoi pour la france normalement il
y avait de réparation qui a d'ailleurs
été abordé dans la décision de la cour
européenne sur le boycott des sables que
le gouvernement français devra verser
aux parties qui ont saisi la cour
européenne et il ya un autre une autre
conséquence qui est extrêmement
importante
depuis une loi de juin 2000 donc cet
ancien déjà on peut saisir la cour de
cassation d'une fort de réexamen de la
scène
alors c'est la cour de cassation
française qui avait condamné nos clients
on peut maintenant saisir la cour de
cassation pour dire est une violation
fondamentale d'une règle décisive d'un
système démocratique européen de liberté
d'expression la cour la cour de
cassation française après une nouvelle
décision et donc il faut re jugé en
partie cet aspect des choses et ça c'est
très important ça teneur examen après
une décision de la cour européenne
c'est très important tout par exemple
rétablir les droits des genres par
exemple ils ont été condamnés à des
amendes
donc ça veut dire que leur casier
judiciaire doivent être corrigés ils ont
été éventuellement condé est dommages
intérêts ceux ci doivent être restitués
par les associations qui ont lancé des
procédures de manière ridicule et en
tout cas il n'ya pas prier du point de
vue de la convention européenne
en fait on a on affichait de 10,1 depuis
dix ans que dure cette procédure que on
ne pouvait pas poursuivre les jambes
pour aix pour avoir exprimé des opinions
et la cour pleine nous donne à me disant
raison entièrement
il ya beaucoup de magistrats français
que ce soit du parquet ou des
juridictions qui nous ont suivis et la
cour de cassation a une vision que je
qualifierais étroite et il est bon que
soient élargies par la cour européenne
merci beaucoup antoine quand je rappelle
que vous êtes avocat à du bds